- [Voiceover] Lift
those heels like you got
six-inch stilettos on!
- I've never worn stilettos!
(upbeat electronic music)
- I'm interested in Cardio Barre
because everyone says it's super intense
and super crazy and it's
kind of like dancing.
I just want to be fucking
like taut like a string,
You know, I want to tighten up.
- I love to dance.
And it's just dancing and exercising.
So, it's like the best combination for me.
I'm interested in losing
some of the weight
that I have gained since P90X (laughs).
- I'm not terribly
interested in Cardio Barre.
I'm just here because this
is the stuff they make us do.
I guess my goal is to
just be kind of lean.
Lose the gravy!
- I have no ballet experience.
So, this is just gonna be an adventure.
We'll see what happens.
After we did P90X, I
got a little skinny fat.
I just want to get rid
of the little mid-section
I've developed now.
- It seems like it's a really
fun way of working out.
So, hopefully it will
make me work out more.
My goal is I would love
to lose a little weight.
I would love to tighten up
my stomach a little bit.
(electronic bell music)
- What is Cardio Barre?
What are we getting ourselves into?
- Okay, Cardio Barre is a ballet-based,
fitness, exercise workout.
It's dancing in some aspects
but it's actually very difficult.
We tone the muscles.
So, it's a lot more
looking for that length
and that ballet body, the dancer's body...
- Yes!
- That everybody wants (laughter) now.
Did you guys bring towels and water?
- We're completely unprepared.
- Let's do it.
(fast piano music)
Swing those hands! In, out, in, out.
- What is this, a little pony trot?
- Ow!
- Ooh, my butt checks!
- [Voiceover] Oh, you're an evil woman.
- [Voiceover] Oh, you like it.
- [Voiceover] No!
- Oh! Oh! Oh!
- My body's just not built for this.
My leg won't stop shaking.
- That was actually miserable for me.
I didn't understand any of the exercises.
What are we doing?
- It was a lot harder than I expected.
Ryan was groaning the whole time.
- Ah, god.
Ah, god.
Ahh, (laughter).
- Fucking up my focus.
So, that was a little bit hard, but...
- If you had the focus of a champion,
that wouldn't bother you.
- You know what, you're done!
- I mean I think I probably
looked a lot stupider
than I felt, but I felt
like it went pretty well.
- I had a great time with this.
At one point, she did compliment my legs.
- [Kaylee] Look at this leg!
(laughter)
(fast piano music)
- All right.
So, I'm skateboarding back from
my first Cardio Barre class
on my own.
I was the only guy there.
And I was clearly the
worst one in the class.
- I'm not very good.
My movements are awkward
and uncoordinated,
and I feel very ashamed of my...
It's actually very discouraging.
- It's been pretty great.
- I'm loving every single second.
- I'm also really loving it.
- I'm bad at it.
- (laughter) Yeah, you can say that again.
I'm trying my darndest,
but it's just not working out for me.
- That's the thing, though,
you've just got to stop trying
and just give yourself to it.
- Shut up, Shane (laughs).
(upbeat orchestra music)
- [Ryan] I called the
Cardio Barre place up
to see how much everyone's actually gone.
At the top, Daysha with 10.
(cash register ring)
- [Shane] Daysha, holy...
- [ Voiceover] Damn girl (clapping).
- [Shane] Holy shit Daysha!
- In second place, me, with seven.
(cash register ring)
- No (laughs).
I'll clap for myself.
Tied for third place is Shane and Macie
with five apiece.
- You have to understand,
out of town and then sick.
- And in last place, in glorious
fashion, is Jen with two.
- [Daysha] Two?
(cash register ring)
- Big old chopsticks (laughter) again.
- I will say I have like
committed to going a lot more
to catch up.
We have two weeks left, right?
- {Shane] (laughter) So you're gonna do...
- What are you gonna
go, seven days a week?
- [Shane] Twice a day for...
- This is our last week of Cardio Barre,
and it has been going amazing.
My butt has gotten like
exponentially bigger
which, you know, can't complain, at all.
Look at that, look at that!
Definitely helped a homey out.
- Hi guys. I'm Richard Giorla
and I'm the creator of Cardio Barre.
I'm really looking forward to taking you
through your last class.
Test Friends, ready?
All right, let's do it!
(laughter)
(upbeat electronic music)
- Good job Shane, one.
- Nice Ryan, good Daysha.
Beautiful Macie.
Straighten your right leg Jen.
Other right leg Jen.
Keep an eye on her for me.
(upbeat electronic music)
Now, don't bounce up, just press up.
Remember exercise just maintains you.
Uncomfortable resistance will change you.
So, take yourself a little further.
(upbeat electronic music)
♫It's time to break now.♫
(upbeat music)
- I loved Cardio Barre.
This has been one of the
best things we've done.
I feel slightly more, I guess, taut.
Every single session ended with me
just floating out of
there, feeling incredible.
- It's not really about
what the scale says.
It's about how I feel
and I always feel fantastic
after these classes.
So, I don't really give a fuck (laughter).
But, let me tell ya' all.
My butt, like, Cardio Barre!
- It just simply isn't for me,
but I could see why people would do this.
It was a lot of fun.
I continually embarrassed
myself week after week.
Really put forth a good effort.
Tried to eat better.
So, if I didn't lose any weight,
I would have been a little
upset because that was my goal
and the fact that I did means I could come
out of this vindicated.
- You're supposed to
grasp what they're doing
just by seeing other people in a mirror.
So, every time I went to
a class which, granted,
was only three times,
I was really, really embarrassed.
Definitely gained weight, though,
because I wasn't exercising
but I was thinking,
"Man, if I had exercised I would deserve
"this extra sandwich."
- I feel like it was
like a really nice way
to start my morning, or to end my night.
I'm really sad that it's over.
I want to keep going.
I got probably stronger
and better at doing it.
I probably did not lose weight
because I've just been eating
everything I want to eat
like fried chicken sandwiches.
- [Voiceover] Yeah, I
know it's really weird.
- [Macie] Oh!!
- [Voiceover] Stop it!
- [Shane] You got it, you got it great!
- Wow!
Okay (laughter).
- I sounded...
- [Shane] What?
- [Ryan] Stop looking like you're an alien
that just landed on Earth, dude!
(laughter)
Stop it Prichard.
- [Shane] And flex!
- [Ryan] This should be good,
this shot, huh (laughter)?
- [Shane] Turn.
- Do you see my butt?
(laughter)
- [Shane] Okay, come
on. Let's start it over.
Bring it back to the top.
You guys are making this so
much harder than it has to be.
(laughter)